[Musique]
comme dans un film canadien dans la
ville mais des indiens dans un cimetière
une série de collages pour faire revivre
les haras rock et les caraïbes
les faire revivre sous les traits de
leurs frères du brésil ou de colombie
menacé eux aussi aujourd'hui
d'extinction ils ont disparu mais pour
moi ils sont toujours là donc il ya
beaucoup de lieux qui sont chargés
chargé d'histoire chargé d' empathie
pour ces gens pour cesser pour l'heure
pour l'heure leur présence absence et
donc c'est ce que j'essaie de rentrer
dans mon projet
hugh laurie est un plasticien dans l'âme
selon le message qu'il veut faire passer
il choisit le collage l'installation la
peinture la photo ou la bd mais dans ses
oeuvres
le plasticien se fait parfois également
historien à la gwadeloup lusine de
beauport donc a été construite à peu
près au même moment où les derniers
groupes d'indiens caraïbes ont disparu
de la grande terre et de l'ensemble delà
de la guadeloupe donc comme s'il y avait
dans le temps une sorte de
correspondance avec j'allais dire la
modernité triomphante de ces machines à
vapeur et et puis bon et malgré tout
donc la disparition d'un peuple qui
avait été génocide et qui a été oublié
et alors je trouvais que cette image là
elle à cette dimension là l'exposition
s'appelle fantôme caraïbes on y trouve
aussi des toiles avec beaucoup de
couleurs des toiles avec des motifs
mystérieux des toiles où se côtoient les
animaux et les esprits c'est la déesse
mère comme la pachamama dans les les
civilisations précolombiennes donc
l'amérique centrale et du sud
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'elle est métamorphiques c'est à dire
aller en même temps anthropomorphes
raisonnement faire une partie grenouille
une partie humaine
donc là on voit bien l'unité qui avait
entre les hommes et la nature pour eux
il n'y avait pas du tout de distinction
entre la nature disparaître pour mieux
réapparaître sous les doigts d'un
artiste les arawak et les caraïbes ont
été les premiers habitants de la
martinique
et comme chacun sait les premiers seront
aussi les derniers